[Music]
hey welcome to everyday I'm today we're
going to talk about pizza burritos and
crazy rich Asians but first watch this
so pretty clearly this is from Florida
we all know that without knowing that
comes from Facebook user rashon Anderson
guess been pretty normal stuff what's
the most daredevil thing that you guys
have done or what do you think what does
this make you think of I think there's
something like peaceful about being so
close to death at any moment I like your
worries could just like disappear
because they because you die I feel like
that when I'm standing by the subway and
the subways coming I'm like I could it
would just take this like this that's
like one calories worth of energy and
you jumped into the tracks before I
haven't realized why well my phone
dropped down and oh well I needed my
phone and there are like six other
people milling about and you know what
they said or did not a thing my
immediate reaction is that man is not
good at sex why it's trying to prove so
no no way I bet he's like doing all
kinds of cool feet stuff stake number
one sex is good feet work possibility
the feet could be involved who knows
what he's doing he's in Florida Ryan I
would hate to have sex with you he's
doing yeah I'm gonna have to say that
guy the guy he knows
yeah I hope he also uses his lawnmower
like you think this guy has a yard
should have a helmet on
he doesn't need protection he's has a
gun in his bad sex the questionable food
we've got a pizza burrito video check
this out this is the pizza rito from
Russo's how some foods on Pearl River
let's is that give you a heart attack
just watching that what do you think man
garlic not to top it yeah garlic knots
mozzarella sticks pasta all inside that
well that's the only bite she took I
don't like this no I got a pamphlet in
the mail from the World Wildlife
Foundation and they were talking about
food waste and how America wastes 40
percent of all of the food that we have
imagine eating that whole thing no one's
eating the whole thing feels so good
like just like pass out and like you
forget everything and maybe you'd be
closer to death everyone is so critical
of food don't eat it like I went to this
party and it was Tex Mex and I brought
Doritos and I didn't hear the end of it
Tex Mex is made up you know what I mean
like sick of people being like
criticizing food if that's a thing let's
just make food and eat it
[Laughter]
[Applause]
it's a way that's wasteful it's wasted
do you what if you finish that well
that's a great point this idea of like
the clean plate club where you got to
finish your play if you're eating more
calories and you need just because you
ate it that's still a type of food waste
okay look
what do you yeah we have 40 percent food
waste other countries are down around
like 17 from the pants it's also just a
calzone
[Applause]
it's a calzone with a bunch of garbage
it's an open-ended half back yeah
there's only a time when people who are
lower like oh man they used to have like
flat pizza they even folded and put
in it and sometimes you would just eat a
slice of it this is a headline crazy
rich Asians Warner Brothers has decided
to make a sequel already because it did
so well at the box office it had an
opening weekend of thirty five point
three million for the first five days
wow this is exciting has anyone here
seen it yeah
pretty what do you guys think about the
movie Nate what do you think about
crazier iterations I loved it I thought
it's great I haven't seen it yet if I
want to though Ryan what do you think
about the movie we're gonna go we might
go tonight okay Hanna what do you think
about crazy rotation I love the book cuz
I read the book a 500 page book did you
read the whole thing no they made a
movie about it why would have to write
the book I think I'm a more dedicated
agency
[Applause]
I remember a previous episode you
awarded Natasha full Asian power yes my
mom saw the movie and I listened to a
podcast about it okay and Constance Wu
the lead yes
went to my rival high school your rival
high school that's really cool yeah I
gotta be in this seat I'm not gonna ask
Chris I'm not gonna put that pressure on
Chris
but I also denied you'll see black
clansmen so okay and Max in the time
just lazy and cheap think maybe I'm
being a terrible white man here yeah so
it's like I think it's great that
there's there's representation and all
this kind of stuff but the most recent
movies but the most recent movies have
had black panther and then it's like
well now all the black people better go
see this because blacks in the title if
we don't do this then it's over I'm not
opposed better the lack of pressure we
got for the last whites always been in
the title too but when Harry Met Sally
anyway during our hiatus I'm gonna go
see them the movie all the movies
obviously autumn racially driven movies
that's my plan
yeah sounds like a fun every movies
ratio let's poke it out of your pocket
dude you'd be lucky to see my pamphlet
[Music]
okay so the comments were a lot of them
were about Hannah's worm from Wooper
Wooper tinkerer it reminds me of a worm
but like in his last moments of life
before dying in the Sun and then Jericho
J says Hannah's worm was more like a
fish on land and it's been a good minute
that's what I'm gonna do over the hiatus
I'm just gonna do the worm every day you
promise I'm going to have the worm down
write it for that we're gonna do
something different right now we're here
right now we'll create the Stefano from
stupid questions every Friday I don't
crowd me sense you also new comic
special coming this January and today
hey turn the tables on you and we're
gonna ask you a couple stupid questions
do it okay what compliment always turns
you to putty party sometimes people say
that I have a woman's butt oh we got a
lady but yeah it's like a size 38 I mean
yo where you at
yeah well you asked to have if no if you
haven't didn't ask this is your question
get in here quick
all right come on you know he's not bad
Alexi for a lady that would be a good
lady Chris if you want to get this putty
but you know what I'm a question go to
you join okay so if you could start a
kiss level band like the band Kiss okay
level of appreciation and fame but you
had to quit comedy would you do that
what I'm in a band like kiss like kiss
like I'm the lead singer of kiss sure
okay
yep and then what do you mean game level
you get the same level of fame and
appreciation and wealth okay
but you but you have to quit comedy no
more comedy oh no more comedy but I'm as
famous as the guys from kiss yeah yeah
would anybody do you think anybody
really cares about comedy though the
answer is a resounding yes okay for the
rest of your life would you rather not
be able to tell the difference between a
muffin and a baby or have cheeto dust on
your fingers I'd say cheeto dust on my
fingers because I bite my nails still to
this day so I constantly have fingers in
my mouth to have an oral fixation it's a
long thing with my love muffin I love
babies
but um yeah I'd rather just have cheeto
dust on my fingers for ebbs I got a
question would you rather fight one
horse-sized duck or ten duck sized
horses I think I'd rather fight one one
horse-sized duck I fight a duck why well
because I feel like you know I grew up
in like you know like the old Brooklyn I
feel like I fought people and lost but
for people that look like horse sized
duck so I guess some kids that you've
seen like in the depths of my
neighborhood that you're like there's no
way that's your human but then a duck
sized horse that's cute
I don't know yeah I don't know if I want
to fight them move it on detach it your
question I did a little bit of
search for this question Thank You our
so currently ham costs 350 a pound on
average okay okay if you were in charge
of all of ham how much would you make
their cost per pound that's like what
gas costs I think right so in a tank
against equivalent to having eight
pounds of ham as president of ham I
would keep it at 350 350 pounds yeah
that's just what it is and that's the
that's the America you live in with me
so and you gotta make sure you don't
point at them you have to do this thing
yeah well how did you keep it it make
that enough I make keep an at three
dollars and fifty cents a pound I'm
gonna open up the borders to him it can
have him that's what I'll do the borders
are open there's no walls you can have
the ham we're not making ham great again
it's always been great feel the ham burn
this is great I hope you enjoy it a
stupid question let me put my finger in
your mouth
[Music]
hi I'm Hannah Dickinson and this is
cheers to you
we're on vacation next week and I'm
kicking it off earlier with the blackout
cheers to you Noah Cyrus for being
swooned by your new boyfriend lil van
for bringing you chicken nuggets I think
it's so romantic you visit him at work
[Music]
cheers to you Kevin Spacey for making a
whole hundred and twenty-six dollars an
opening day of your new movie
billionaire boys club I bet all six
people walked out when they realize it's
actually not a documentary about all
your victims cheers to you Bruno from
being a robust cat in high demand thanks
for being a positive force for the rest
of us fat pussies cheer CEO Heidi Klum
for carrying around baby teeth is good
luck I was wondering what you did with
them after drinking their blood cheers
to you ariana grande for thinking Pete
Davidson for existing good to know our
standards are the same Cheers
did you guys see my new shoes yeah they
kind of look like my shoes wait what's
up what's happening Brian are you gonna
go to a rave during the hiatus I don't
know I might just do this throughout the
movie a crazy rich Asians is coming up
so we won't be here next week but come
back on Tuesday September 4th and we'll
see you then thanks for watching every
damn day
[Music]
you